Jetzt ist es besser.
Also jetzt sollte es zumindest wieder funktionieren.
Jetzt auch mal refreshen.
Jetzt ist es gut. Jetzt ist es nice. Jetzt sparkt es nicht rum, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, der Boss, ich habe jetzt refreshed. Du hast das letzte was du geschrieben hast, war, dass du schon ein BIOS Update gemacht hast.
Also einfach booten solltest, macht dein PC irgendwelche Piepscodes oder so was beim Start oder startet er einfach gar nichts.
Geht dann wenigstens der Lüfter an, sowohl an Grafikkarte als auch an GPU.
Ich habe mir gedacht wir gucken ein paar alte Videos oder sowas, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe nichts Spezielles vor, echt nicht.
Weder großartige Progas noch Spiele oder sowas, ich bin etwas demotiviert gerade.
Bei mir heute eingefallen ist, dass ich nächste Woche wieder arbeiten gehen muss, da habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Also wirklich gar nichts.
Aber alles richtig, ja, Woodface.
Alle Lüfter gehen und dann kommt die LED mit. Was die LED mit VGA Fehler am Mainboard? Aha, du hast eine LED für Grafikkarten, das ist natürlich der Wahnsinn.
Ich kenne bloß diese zweistelligen Codes, die man teilweise als Mainboard anzeigen lassen kann, das ist ein krasser Mainboard.
Aber wenn man am anderen Rechner geht, das ist echt merkwürdig.
Ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, da fällt mir spontan jetzt nicht so viel ein.
Aber es hat gerade jemand was Gutes im Chat geschrieben, wenn du in der CPU, wobei die geht ja nicht, die schaltet sich ja aus, sobald was im PCI Express-Slot drinne steckt.
Die CPU-Grafik, oder? Schaltet die sich aus? Nee, warum sollte die sich ausschalten? Da bin ich bescheuert.
Wird sie nicht ausschalten.
Dann solltest du dir mal überlegen, ob du die Arbeit nicht wechselst. Nee, so schlimm ist das nicht. Wenn ich wieder angefangen habe, ist das eigentlich okay.
Ich habe bloß keinen Bock. Sagen wir mal, das kann doch nicht sein, dass ich der Einzige bin, der wenn er Urlaub einen Monat hatte, keinen Bock mehr hat wieder auf die Arbeit zu gehen.
Da kann die Arbeit noch so geil sein. Wirklich Bock hat auch keiner drauf.
Ich wollte mal kurz was nachgucken. Ich muss nämlich noch kurz was installsorgen.
Irgendwas für einen komischen Container muss ich löschen. Kein Kommentar zu meinem tollen Containernamen wieder.
Das Discount lieber.
Ups
Aijaja, wer ist Container?
Ehm, warte, was? Start?
Nee, Quatsch, was will ich mal?
Lounge, laut
Hab ich festgestellt, dass meine Home Assistant Installation nicht funktioniert
Und ich werd jetzt doch die offizielle Docker Installation von denen nehmen
Da muss man nichts machen für all diesem extra Container, das ich wieder wegschmeißen kann
Also quasi Container, Container Rised
Schaut gar nicht mal auf
Ah, Updates machen, ja
Keyhole läuft, ja
Achso, ja, das ist der Server, den wir zusammen eingerichtet haben im letzten Stream
Ich hab's jetzt doch wieder so gemacht mit meinem klassischen Setup, LXT Container
Und, äh, gut ist, ist vom Handlinger einfach besser
Ah, das ist Piehole, ne?
Klingt irgendwie ein bisschen versaut
Quai, was meinste?
Also, wenn du denkst, wir machen noch ein großartiges Progress
Irgendwie hab ich halt keinen Bock, was zu machen
Ich muss jetzt einfach nur streben machen, dass ich bisschen was labern kann
Nebenbei machen wir irgendwas
Und wir gucken uns alle Videos an
So, was wirst du denn jetzt mit der Grafikkarte gewesen?
Kann das einfach am Ramm liegen?
Eher nicht, wenn das mit einer anderen Grafikkarte geht
Äh, Puffi, Moment, die Google Werbung, die geht mir massiv auf den Sack
Die, die Google, die, ähm, die Google, was ist das? Google Maps oder so Werbung
Die ist so nervig, die kommt mittlerweile vor jedem Stream, den ich auf dem
Deswegen hab ich jetzt ja auch wieder das Piehole am Start, ja
Ähm, die, äh, Google Maps Werbung geht mir so auf den Sack jeden Stream auf Twitch, den du anmachst
Und die haben so einen nervigen Sound, ja
Ich bin da jemand, ich hab sogar teilweise nachts
Gut, der Stream läuft halt einfach weiter, weil ich mach dann auf dem Handy noch einen Stream an, guck dann irgendwie ein bisschen Twitch
Und penne dann ein
Und das ist überhaupt kein Ding, ja
Ich mein, ich hab selten Streamer an, die wild rumschreien, das passt schon
So, und zwischendurch kommt da dann zu einer Werbung
Und da kommt dann diese nervige, diese nervige Google Maps Werbung
Die geht ja an sich noch, plus dass die zum Schluss irgendwie machen
Uuuh, uuuh, uuuh, uuuh
Oder so in der Werbung, äh
Und dann mach ich immer auffahren, dann könntest du immer Google direkt gleich, gleich in die Fresse rausschlagen, äh
Leider ist Google, äh, nicht materiell so in dem Sinn, ja
Da bin ich übelst aggressiv auf die Google Werbung immer
Ich mein, das ist normal, wenn ich irgendwas aus dem Schlaf reiß
Uuuh, uuuh
Hast keinen Bock mehr
Also das mit, das mit der Grafikkarte der Bossesberg ist echt merkwürdig
Kannst du irgendwelche guten Home Assistant kompatiblen, äh
Kannst du irgendwelche guten Home Assistant kompatiblen Produkte erfüllen?
Ähm, ich muss mal kurz
Alter, was mit dem Stream wieder los?
Spack die Telekom wieder?
Ähm, ja, also, äh, kennst du irgendwelche guten Home Assistant kompatiblen Produkte?
Das Schöne an Home Assistant ist ja, also du kannst erst in diese Components Sache mal reingucken
Aber das Schöne an Home Assistant ist ja, dass es eigentlich mit fast allem funktioniert
Es sei denn der Hersteller ist super, ähm, proprietär und hat gar keine Schnittstellen, selbst inoffizielle, die man ansprechen kann
Ähm, ich weiß nicht, ich hab den, hat vielleicht, nutzt auch jemand von euch Home Assistant und hat den, ähm,
Diesen Mini Shitstorm mit Logitech mitgekriegt
War eigentlich genau das Typisch, typisch Hersteller, ey
Also typisch verplante Hersteller, die eigentlich überhaupt keinen Plan haben, so
Zwar, ähm, die haben, die haben wir hier
Ach, die haben's schon rausgegeben, ne, oder?
Harmony?
Ah ne, genau, die haben ja hier diese Logitech
Ja, genau, Sebaro
Die haben ja hier diese Harmony Hub-Geschichte
Und die haben halt so eine eigene Komponente in Home Assistant programmiert
Die diesen Harmony Hub von Logitech nicht über die Cloud anspricht, sondern lokal
Und, ähm, ich mein, diese lokale API von Logitech war so
Sagen wir mal, im besten Fall halboffiziell, ne
Und jetzt hat Logitech gesagt
So quasi durch die
So still und heimlich wäre, oder weniger, jetzt ist die lokale API weg
Ey, und da haben sich die Leute aufgeregt auf Twitter
Über Logitech, äh
Ging übelst ab und haben mir mal erzählt, wie scheiße das ist, dass jetzt die Cloud von Logitech verwenden sollen
Wo sie Recht haben
Und vor allem, dass die selbstgebauten Funktionen von ihnen besser ist als die Funktionen von Logitech
Und da würde ich mir an der Stelle von Logitech echt schon Gedanken machen
Also der Boss, ich kann dir leider, also mir fällt jetzt zu der Grafikkartengeschichte auch nichts weiter ein, ehrlich gesagt
Vor allem, dass das Mainboard mein Grafiker
Kannst du den mal in den anderen PC Express Slot stecken, vielleicht?
Das wäre doch mal eine Idee
Ja gut, wenn die auch in einem anderen PC Express Slot nicht geht, da kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das Mainboard kaputt ist
Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
So, machen wir uns auf der Kiste ein, machen jetzt die Home Assistant Install Action
Was läuft hier so? Ach, ich hab einfach nur Streben angemacht, so ein bisschen Schwätzen
Und ich muss mein Home Assistant neu installieren, aber das, äh
Das hab ich grad vorm Stream angefangen, mir hat mir gedacht, ey komm
Wenn du das machst, kannst du einfach Stream anmachen und ein bisschen schwätzen mit den Leuten
Haha, ich äh, Bouncer, ich wollte es grad sagen, äh, kaufte eine Nvidia-Karte, aber
Nee, nee, ist schon okay, sowas willst du nicht hören, zumal es ja auch bescheuert ist
Es muss ja auch in deinem Rechner funktionieren
Mir fällt aber leider auch nichts sinnvolles ein, da kann ich dir leider nicht weiterhelfen
Mal gucken, ob das Shit jetzt funktioniert
So, wir pippen jetzt mal so, wie man es schön, so wie man es machen sollte, mal wieder ein
CURL-Befehl nach Bash und gucken, was abgeht
Fax macht YouTube, ich weiß nicht, keine Ahnung
Ich kenn den nicht
Hass IO's beste Domain, ja in Deutsch schon
Aber hast du bestimmt schon, ne, der Boss, hast bestimmt schon mal dein Mainboard eingegeben
Bei Google in Verbindung mit AMD oder mit Sega, Grafikkarte oder so
Vielleicht gibt es da irgendwelche bekannten Sachen
Also die beste Domain ist jetzt, die hab ich mir jetzt gekauft, hier, Froggers.yz
Ja, Max.tv ist auch geil
So, Docker, der Docker jetzt eigentlich
Der Docker dockert nicht, oder?
Der Docker spackt rum
Warum spackt denn der Docker rum, was ist denn das für ein Kacke ey
Der Docker spackt, guck mal
Der Docker spackt sich übelst einen ab
Der exited sich immer
Und dann startet er sich neu
Und exited sich wieder
Weil Docker doch prinzipiell eigentlich geht
Meine Domainidee
Domainscam hatte ich schon, äh
Erzählt der eine, der mir MaxFPS.de verkauft hat dann
Ok, warum, warum, warum spackt denn der Docker rum
Beziehungsweise, besser gesagt, warum spackt die Home Assistant Docker install rum
Was ist denn da los
Was ist denn da
Scamas
Exiteds
139, gucken wir mal danach
Home Assistant, exited, 139
Tja
Da gibt's wohl denn wirklich was drin, oder?
Max.xyz, naja, ne
Ich hab jetzt so viel, ich hab mir in letzter Zeit so viele Domains, in den letzten paar Jahren so viele Domains gekauft
Die einfach nur weil sie irgendwie cool sind, das ergibt keinen Sinn
Braucht den Scheiß überhaupt nicht
Ich hatte da mal eine Frage
Wie viel bringen sich Vierenschutz wirklich, denn es gibt Unterschied zwischen Free und gekauft
Ich hab da, wo wir gerade beim heutigen Titel des Streams sind
Ich hab da ein Video vorbereitet zu diesem Thema
Und zwar
Da ist es
Anti-Virus
Gefährlich, ne
Anti-Virus-Software noch sinnvoll oder sogar gefährlich
Anziehung geht genau das
Wenn du es kurz willst
Ohne das Video zu gucken
Braucht man nicht, Windows Defender reicht
Das kommt auch so als Fazit im Video raus dann am Ende
Warum spackt denn der Docker jetzt rum?
Datet sich und stoppt sich, datet sich und stoppt sich, warum macht der Docker denn so?
Bestimmt irgendwas nicht installiert, was der haben will und was sie nicht auf ihre Seite geschrieben haben
Und jetzt, jetzt spackt das rum
Ok, ich werf das Ding nochmal weg
Werfe nochmal weg
Mach noch einen Container und dann guck ob der Docker will
Nee, nee
Das wird helfen, das wirst du nicht
Außerdem
Qualifiziert deine Freundin da irgendwas zu solche Aussagen zu treffen?
Kennt die sich damit aus?
Die haben damit was gelernt oder so?
Die haben damit Erfahrung?
Ich find's immer interessant, wie Leute dann zu solchen
Zu so einem Fazit immer kommen
Eigentlich gar nix wissen zu
Fabio und mein, so sieht's aus
Hier hat man Grills, wenn schon
So, vielleicht will der Docker jetzt
Docker blitz
Die Musik klaut stärker, ok
Jetzt wollte ich das eigentlich gar nicht anklicken, zu null
Easy
So
So was gibt es ja im Endeffekt schon
Ich hab ja früher immer die Norton Internet Security Suite
Ewig her
Es war so zu Zeiten, wo man das DSL Modem noch direkt am Windows ME oder sowas Rechner dran hatte
Nee, es war nicht Norton, es war zu Mantek, oder?
Ich glaub, das ist der gleiche Laden, egal
Und das Ding hat auch alle 5 Sekunden gespammt, dass ein Hackerangriff abgewehrt wurde
Macht es jetzt, wie die das hier geschrieben haben
Man erkennt, wenn eine Ubuntu-Anleitung outdated ist, wenn sie Abget verwenden
Es gibt ja immer noch Leute, die Abget auch in neue Anleitungen reinschreiben
Wobei Abt die viel schönere Variante ist, weil die kann alles was Abt und Abget tun können und ist kürzer
Und eine bessere Autovervollständigung
Pacman Master Race, ja seh ich
Our beste
Da gibt es ja auch ein paar Dinger
Der Joghurt ist nicht schlecht
So hat er jetzt installiert
Mal gucken, ob der Docker jetzt tut
Mal gucken, ob der Docker sich jetzt dazu überreden lässt
Ja, man benutzt nur noch Abt-Sybar
Vielleicht sollte ich auch eine neue Docker-Version nochmal installieren
Vielleicht packt er einfach nur die Ubuntu-Docker-Version rum
Ja, das machen wir jetzt, wenn es nicht funktioniert
Ja, wie gesagt, eigentlich hatte ich heute vor, dass wir uns ein paar YouTube-Videos angucken
Beziehungsweise alle YouTube-Videos
In der Hoffnung, dass ich 2019 wieder Motivation finde
YouTube-Videos zu machen
Weil wenn ich auf YouTube drauf gucke, da hab ich schon echt wieder keinen Bock mehr
Ein paar Filmen von Transformer-Filmen kann man jetzt ja auch nicht allzu viel erwarten, oder?
Die sind jetzt ja nicht gerade bekannt dafür, dass sie irgendwie tiefgreifend ausgeklügelte Story-Elemente enthalten
Total AV
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das gibt
Es gibt immer wieder neues Zeug
Lasst den Windows-Defender oder lasst Windows einfach jede Stunde mal einen Pop-Up machen
Während Signaturen werden aktualisiert, es wurde keine Bedrohung gefunden oder irgendwie sowas
Dann wirkt es sicher
Oh, der Docker macht was
Der Docker ist schon wieder abgekackt
Alter, warum ist denn das Warping in der Scheißnetz?
Was ist das denn?
Immer wenn ich ein Kronk-Video schaue, immer ein Unge-Video
Okay
Tja, so ist das halt bei YouTube
Der Docker macht nichts
Der stoppt sich und startet sich da wieder
Entziehungsweise die Home-Assistant-Docker-Installation ist der Meinung
Sich die ganze Zeit stoppen und starten zu müssen
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht der Zweck der Übung, so wie es aussieht
Obwohl ich...
Noch mal testen
Bussi-Box
Was macht ihr eigentlich zu meiner...
Zu meiner geilen...
Durchsuchbaren Clipboard, zu meinem geilen durchsuchbaren Clipboard-Manager
Doch nice, oder?
Ah, da kann ich jetzt so suchen
Docker?
Das sind doch die Docker-Befehle
Das ist doch sehr, sehr, sehr nice, oder?
Doch echt?
Und je nachdem, was du einkämpfst, zeigt dir natürlich...
Äh, Kiste HD
Wollten wir mal eine Linux für einen holen, welche ist da gut?
Meinst du Virtualisierungstechnik, oder was du darauf installieren soll?
Also meinst du, was du zum Virtualisieren nehmen sollst, oder was du in der VM für eine Linux-Distribution installieren sollst?
Sondern Docker spackt immer noch, das geht echt auf den Sack
Ich installiere jetzt einfach mal...
Nicht die Ubuntu-Variante von Docker, sondern wir installieren jetzt einfach mal die offizielle...
Ja, habe ich ein...
Nein, nicht Stormel
Nicht Stormel, die wollte ich ganz...
Ja, wau, da guckste, ne?
War das ja auch noch nicht so richtig, mal war es nicht
Ich habe eh das Gefühl, ich bin da nicht so...
Äh, bewandt
Was das angeht, beziehungsweise...
Irgendwie verlässt mich da relativ schnell so...
Die Motivation, da mich irgendwie anzustrengen, ich weiß nicht, das ist irgendwie...
Ganz schlimm, äh...
Okay, ähm...
Ja, genau
Ich bin auch immer auf dem Keks, also...
Prinzipiell würde ich ja schon...
Gerne, so ist das nicht, aber...
Für mich ist das immer...
Wirklich anstrengend, sich mit Leuten auseinanderzusetzen, ich hab da irgendwie...
Aber ich bin auch nicht normal, was das angeht
Die Zeit von Toni
Der Typ, der wiegt heute wahrscheinlich das Doppelte und ist verheiratet
Also, dass er verheiratet ist, hab ich mal wirklich irgendwo gelesen
Habt ihr euch da mal verabredet für nächstes Jahr?
Silvester, ne?
Silvester werde ich dieses Jahr nichts Großartiges machen, da werde ich mir da...
Family Raclette spachteln
Ich hab's ja letztens im Stream schon erzählt, meine...
Alkoholresistenzen sind quasi im Minusbereich ungefähr
Nachdem ich jetzt quasi schon über 10 Jahre nicht mal richtig besoffen gewesen bin
Das ist quasi Toxic Debuff oder sowas
Junge, was machst du, lad dich zu Silvester ein
Ich... äh... davon aus, dass... also erstens wird es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen komisch ankommen
Weil ich meine, wir sind jetzt ja eigentlich so wirklich so dicke und irgendwie kennt ihr auch sonst keiner
Richtig
Also schon, aber das ist... also wenn ich die einlade
Da müsste man wahrscheinlich die Mutter noch einladen
Weil die Mutter kennt meine Mutter
Oh ne, das wird ja schrecklicher
Ne ne
Das soll man nicht
Und außerdem will ich an Silvester mich...
Einfach nur in Ruhe ein bisschen futtern, ein bisschen schwätzen hier noch
Und dann mach ich irgendwann, keine Ahnung, 22 Uhr mache ich Stream an
Richtig No-Life, Silvester-Stream oder sowas dann
Und dann gucken wir uns dann die Spiele-Trailer für 2019 an
Und mache einen Top oder Flop, ob es was wird
Und so wie ich mich kenne, bin ich wahrscheinlich der Ansicht, dass fast jedes Spiel ein Flop wird
Zumindest Game-Spaß technisch
Und dann sagen die Leute dann wieder, Max, du darfst das nicht alle so negativ sehen
Du siehst die Spiele immer so negativ und dann kommt das Game raus und BÄM Spiele sind scheiße
Insurgency Sandstorm, das kenne ich sogar
Ich könnte das sogar aushaben
Das ist doch dieses realistische Militär-Setting
In der heutigen Zeit mit ziemlich viel Damage, den du frierst
Also quasi so ein modernes Militär CSGO
Das habe ich nie gespielt
Ist das rundenbasiert?
Also CS, Tod, nächste Runde warten bis Respawn oder Battlefield, du kannst Revive werden und Spawnen
Der Baro hat schon Weihnachtsgeld gespendet
Da gibt es so Wellen
Das ist übrigens eine Sache, die ich auch in Overwatch in den unteren Ligen geil finden würde
Weil das würde dafür sorgen, dass auch in den Noob-Ligen die Leute zusammenlaufen
Aber vergesst mal, Verbesserungsvorstellungen in Overwatch
Den Weihnachtsgeld habe ich wahrscheinlich überrascht
Ich hatte den ganzen Dezember Urlaub
Einmal kriege ich eine Nachricht von meinem Chef
Nach dem Motto, Max, ich hätte da noch einen Brief für dich
Kann ich dir den am besten zustellen? Du bist ja gerade nicht da
Habe ich schon gedacht, ich habe irgendwas angestellt
War mir zwar nichts bewusst, so glücklich
Aber ich habe gedacht, was ist jetzt los?
Insinn ist die Abmahnung raus
Für was auch immer
Du weißt ja nicht
Da und da, kannst du hinschicken
Hat er hingeschickt, habe ich reingeguckt
1500 Euro, Bäm
Gut
Sag ich jetzt nichts, nice
GG
Also nicht in dem Umschlag, in dem Umschlag stand drinne
Sonst wäre das ja wahrscheinlich finanztechnisch für die Firma nicht so sinnvoll
Also stand drinne, dass es dann das gibt zusätzlich
Obwohl es ja schon mal Weihnachtsgeld zusätzlich schon gab
Also habe ich quasi dieses Jahr an Weihnachten irgendwie
Die Kohle gekriegt fällt mir gerade so ein
Irgendwie 6K oder so
Alter, wollen sie es aber wissen
Ah, ich weiß
Zumindest bisher
Ich habe was Finanzen angeht
Bin ich der größte Noob eigentlich schlechter
Also was so Sachen angeht wie, wo kann man sein Geld am besten anlegen
Oder was mache ich jetzt mit der Kohle am besten
Da bin ich der größte Noob aller Zeiten, habe ich keine Ahnung
Aber eine Sache kommt mir echt zugute
Ich kaufe fast nichts
Das ohne Scheiß
Also wenn ich eine Sache auch in den letzten Jahren über gelernt habe
So diese Geschichten, die ganzen Videos auf YouTube so nach dem Motto
Das ist die Masche der Reichen, so geht man mit Geld um
Das kann man alles vergessen
Die einfachste Regel, die es irgendwie gibt um, nennen wir es mal, reich zu werden
Die ist so banal und logisch
Jetzt einfach mehr Geld behalten als auszugeben
Und das ist das, was so viele Leute nicht auf die Reihe kriegen
Wenn ich mir das teilweise angucke
Dass 144 Herzmonitore auf Kredit gekauft werden
Ich denke, Alter, da kaufste halt keinen 144 Herzmonitor
Das ist dann jemand, der hat da noch, keine Ahnung
Noch das Auto irgendwie monatlich zu bezahlen
Wahrscheinlich noch den Fernseh
Und was ich letztens gesehen habe, ist eine Werbung von irgendeinem Kreditladen
So nach dem Motto, für Leute, die immer Poolparties feiern wollen
Yeah, irgendwie so war es in der Richtung, stand da drauf
Und da habe ich mir gedacht, okay, Alter, was wollt ihr jetzt von mir?
Habe ich so hinten drauf geguckt
So nach dem Motto, haben sie quasi so erzählt, wie du das Jahr über bei ihnen ein Kredit nehmen kannst
So nach dem Motto, ja, dann nimmst du dir am Anfang des Jahres was
Dann nimmst du dir danach noch was, dass du in den Urlaub fahren kannst
Dann machst du Poolparty, weil das Geld ist ja alle
Und deswegen musst du ja nochmal einen neuen Kredit aufnehmen, machst du Poolparty
Und dann, die haben da quasi Werbung dafür gemacht, dass man super easy bei ihnen 3x im Jahr einen Kredit kriegt
Ich habe gedacht, warum sollte man sowas tun?
Ich verstehe es nicht
Wenn es ja irgendwie darum geht, dass man mit dem Geld was machen will
Also mal angenommen
Mal angenommen, nennen wir jetzt mal zum Beispiel Hardwarerad
Den weiß ich, da hat jetzt einiges Unternehmen gegründet
Und wenn der jetzt sagt, ey Leute, ich brauche für das und die und die Kunde, brauche ich jetzt mal schnell Kohle
Und nimmt sich ihren Kredit auf, quasi als Investition sozusagen zu sagen
Hä, ich nehme jetzt die Kohle jetzt, aber ich habe da draus vor mehr Kohle zu machen
Da sage ich ja gar nichts dagegen
Ich finde einen 144-Hertz-Monitor
Oder für eine Poolparty oder für ein Urlaub
Was kriegen irgendwie viele Leute nicht gebacken, da habe ich den Eindruck
Warte mal, wie oft habe ich eigentlich schon Updates jetzt auf dem Ding installiert? 50.000 Mal, oder?
So sehr es mir auf den Sack geht
Mit der Bahn zu fahren teilweise
Auto fahren ist auch nicht der Weisheitsletzter Schluss nach Frankfurt, morgen ist es rein
Aber ich war kurz davor
Ich war kurz davor, dass ich gesagt habe
Ich war nichts in dem Auto
Aber das hat im Prinzip auch nicht wirklich Sinn
Ich müsste entweder weiter wegparken
Muss ich dann quasi dann erstmal irgendwie über die Brücke sonst wohin laufen
Oder ich muss das Parkhaus bezahlen bei uns
Es ist im Prinzip auch kacke
Es ist alles irgendwie kacke
Aber nichtsdestotrotz ist quasi kein Auto haben
Und kein Auto unterhalten
Das ist nun gar nicht so schlecht was die Kohle angeht
Und auch wenn die Bahnpreise immer teurer werden
Im Prinzip gehe ich davon aus, dass ich immer noch weniger bezahle
Die Fahrzeuge sind wirklich total kurz
Ja, Wortes, es ist so
Ich gehe auch davon aus, dass es viele machen
Also kaufen würde ich es mir eh nicht
Also wenn ich irgendwann der Meinung bin
Ich brauche mal irgendwie so einen... keine Ahnung
Mal angenommen, irgendwann sind Elektroautos wirklich geil, von ich nicht ausgehe.
Weil ich nicht glaube, dass Elektroautos so wirklich die Zukunft sind.
Wenn ich überlege, was du da alles reinstecken musst, da so ein Ding überhaupt gebaut werden kann.
Dann würde ich das wahrscheinlich auch so machen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich mir wirklich was kaufen würde für irgendwie 150k oder so.
Selbst wenn man sich das kaufen kann, das ist irgendwie übertrieben, ja.
Das würde ich wahrscheinlich auch mit irgendwie oder das raten machen.
Regel nicht normal, dass YouTube meine ich das würde was regeln, wenn ich dann auch YouTube Videos machen würde.
So, wie installiert man jetzt auch vom Ubuntu neue Docker-Versionen?
Ah ja, UPDATE in 2K19, da.
Von allen Hostern, wo man einfach so Server spawnen kann, finde ich Digital Ocean echt der beste.
Digital Ocean ist echt cool, ist halt nicht der billigste.
Hab ich das Repo schon geadded?
Die machen es aber kompliziert, ein Repo hinzuzukommen.
Mal gucken, ob es wieder mit der offiziellen Docker-Version besser funktioniert.
Was ist das für eine Musik? Das ist Mario Galaxy.
Ja, neues Testament. Ich gehe auch nicht davon aus, dass Elektroautos mal irgendwann das sein werden, was sich hier Großteil der Leute holt.
Ich habe da eh so meine Zweifel, ob man das auf die Reihe kriegt, das ordentlich herzustellen jemals.
Ich überlege, was du für einen Aufwand treiben musst, um Akkus zu bauen.
Vor allem das Problem an Akkus ist, dass Akkus nicht scaleen gescheit mit dem Gewicht.
Was meint ihr, warum es keine Elektro-Flugzeuge gibt?
Mal gucken, ob es die aus Elektro-Züge geben wird, quasi ohne Oberleitung und sowas.
Akkus scaleen halt schlecht, was das Gewicht angeht.
Umso schwerer die werden, umso weniger lohnt sich das.
Wenn ich mal gucke, was da so reingesteckt werden muss, um quasi ein Elektroauto zu produzieren,
habe ich eben eine Zweifel, ob das umweltfreundlicher ist.
Ja ja, das Gewicht nicht unbedingt bei Autos, aber das Ding wird halt größer.
Du kannst bestimmt mit einem Elektroauto einen doppelt so großen Akku fahren.
Ist halt die Frage, ob du damit so einen Kleintransporter rumkurven willst, dass du deine Akku dabei hast.
Ja, und zu schwer werden die Dinge auch, deswegen gibt es keine Elektro-Flugzeuge.
Es gibt ja, es ist genau so, es gibt Tests, aber so wirklich.
Also, was ich halt ziemlich beknackt finde, ihr habt es vielleicht auch mitgekriegt,
dass in Frankfurt sollte es ja ein Dieselfahrverbot geben.
Warte mal, ich habe Docker installiert.
Wie startet man?
Docker failed, warum?
Wo ist denn jetzt das Problem?
Doxor, wo ist das Problem?
Ach, könnte das das sein, dass der Home Assistant auch damit irgendwelche Probleme hat?
So, ja, Silent Pain sehe ich genauso.
Und zwar zu diesem ganzen, Alter, ist das ja ein Operation not permitted.
Bäm, das ist ja alles nicht permitted, ja.
Zu diesem ganzen Fahrverbotzeug kann ich sagen, dass ich das prinzipiell für keine schlechte Sache halte,
dass es, also rein vom Prinzip her, dass es weniger Autos in der Innenstadt gibt.
Diesen Teil davon finde ich sinnvoll, weniger Autos in der Stadt.
Ich meine, es muss nicht sein, dass du am Hauptbahnhof quasi immer über die Straße laufen kannst.
Das an sich finde ich gut, aber ich finde die Kombination irgendwie bespeuert.
Ich meine, erstens wurden die Leute ja eh schon mal gefickt, die sich Dieselautos gekauft haben.
Oder gesagt wurde in Deutschland, ach nee, was ist das, da sei der Selbstvertrag.
Also die wurden eh schon mal gefickt.
Jetzt haben sie so ein Ding.
Jetzt dürfen sie damit demnächst noch mal nicht in die Stadt fahren.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist, warum kann man nicht sagen, unser Ziel ist es, weniger Autos in den Innenstädten zu haben.
Und man baut den Nahverkehr quasi aus, dass die Leute eine Alternative haben.
Weil wenn die Leute eine Alternative hätten, die jetzt mit dem Auto fahren, die wirklich gut ist,
die zuverlässig ist, die funktioniert und die vielleicht auch billiger ist,
dann würden viele Leute sagen, fahre ich nicht mit dem Auto.
Ist im Prinzip doch eigentlich ganz logisch, oder?
Wenn du eine Alternative hast, die angenehmer ist, auf die du dich verlassen kannst,
die vielleicht sogar noch günstiger ist, dann könnte man auch sagen,
okay, für die Hardcore Leute, dann könnte ich es auch vertreten, weil man sagt,
okay, wir führen ein Fahrverbot ein, weil wir haben jetzt hier Alternativen geschaffen.
Das kann ich verstehen irgendwo.
Aber losgelöst zu sagen, wir wollen ein Fahrverbot machen, ohne Alternativen zu haben,
das ist ja einfach komplett Banane, das kann ja nicht funktionieren.
Du müsstest halt ordentlich, du müsstest massiv Kohle da reinschicken.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht umsonst so, dass die Bahn sackt.
Die Bahn sackt, weil sie die letzten, keine Ahnung, 15 Jahre keine Kohle ausgegeben haben, oder?
Naja, das stimmt nicht, dass sie keine Kohle ausgegeben haben, ist nicht richtig.
Aber dass an vielen Stellen eben nichts gemacht wurde.
Ich meine, wenn man sich anguckt, dass irgendwie, was war das?
Zwei Drittel der ICE sind kaputt, aber jetzt sind wir so, sie fahren noch, aber irgendwas ist kaputt.
Es ist halt an vielen Stellen ein bisschen viel gespart worden die letzten Jahre,
dass es halt viel geiler aussieht, als es ist.
Also ich habe hier so meine Zweifel, ob wir den Docker-Stell noch irgendwie auf die Reihe kriegen.
Naja, uns.
Ach, das habe ich ja schon gelöscht.
Also der Docker-Kram, der funktioniert irgendwie nicht so recht, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ja, und das verstehe ich halt nicht.
Und es gibt ja, es ist ja nicht so, dass es da keine Konzepte für gebe, was man machen könnte für Nahverkehrsgeschichte.
Es gibt ja da richtig abgedrehte Sachen mit quasi so Waggons, die du quasi während der Fahrt aneinander kuppeln kannst und sowas.
Ich meine, klar ist das irgendwie Zukunftsmusik, das ist logisch, aber ich denke mir halt, Glasfaser war 2005 auch noch Zukunftsmusik.
Und Korea hat angefangen Glasfaser auszubauen zu einer Zeit, wo halt, ja, das noch neu war.
Und man sieht da, 10 Jahre, 15 Jahre später haben die auf einmal ultrageil sind.
Ah, irgendwann muss man halt auch mal sagen, man macht jetzt was.
Aber die Kombination verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht, dass auf der einen Seite irgendwie was von Fahrverbot und Umwelt gelabert wird.
Auf der anderen Seite man nicht mal irgendwie auf die glorreiche Idee kommt, dass man den Leuten irgendwie Alternativen bieten muss.
Wie soll das denn funktionieren sonst?
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Du kannst doch nicht sagen, es gibt keine Alternativen, aber du kannst das Auto nicht mehr mit dem Auto nicht mehr dahin fahren.
Das kann man nicht machen, das geht doch nicht.
Ich meine, es geht logisch gesehen nicht.
Was ist dieses Max, ich weiß es nicht.
Ach, wir wollten ja eigentlich Max-Videos gucken.
Das ist nicht billig, ja, und wie gesagt, ich bezahle relativ viel Steuern.
Gut, in den letzten Jahren habe ich sogar was zurück gekriegt, weil ich halt viel Zeug gekauft habe.
Aber im Prinzip, anteilmäßig denke ich mal, dass ich relativ viel Steuern bezahle.
Und ich hätte gar kein Problem damit, sogar mehr Steuern zu bezahlen, wenn ich wüsste, dass das in irgendwas läuft für meine Interessen.
Na ja.
Kott-YouTube-Kanal, da bin ich zuletzt Kott gemacht.
Oh, ich habe ein Gameplay-Play auf das 4 gemacht.
Ja, also ich vermisse auch irgendwie so ein bisschen den Plan dahinter.
Ist ja, wenn ich mir das so angucke, gucken wir uns zum Beispiel bei Intel an.
Intel hat immer Roadmaps.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kenne die aktuell Intel-Roadmap nicht, aber das geht ja auch gar nicht darum.
Also du hast eine Roadmap so nach dem Motto, okay, was stellen wir uns so die nächsten 5 bis 10 Jahre vor?
Die Roadmap kann sich beim Umsetzen als nicht haltbar oder Blödsinn erweisen.
Aber so eine Roadmap sagt zumindest, dass man das vorhat.
Und dass es nicht irgendwas ist, was man einfach nur hingeschrieben hat, sondern man möchte das auch machen.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir sowas überhaupt haben.
Zumindest habe ich das Gefühl, es gibt es irgendwie nicht.
Ich lese plötzlich nach dem Motto, ja, es wird jetzt ganz viel in die Bahn investiert und es wird so viel besser.
Und dann frage ich mich immer so, ja, okay, ich würde mir jetzt gerne mal durchlesen, wie man sich das vorstellt.
Nee, gibt es nicht.
Oder vielleicht gibt es das irgendwo mit ganz viel geschwuppelt.
Das ist ja auch so, wenn Agenda ist verabschieden, kann man immer gut.
Ach, da war die Agenda, Agenda 2038 oder irgendwie sowas.
So weit weg ist, wo sich eh kein Mensch mehr dran erinnern kann.
So, also der Dockerkacke funktioniert nicht.
Muss ich irgendwie anders einmal angucken.
Oh, Snap habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Da haben wir Container in Container in Container.
Das geht doch bestimmt dann.
Wenn Container in Container nicht funktioniert, funktioniert doch bestimmt Container in Container in Container.
Oder was meint ihr?
Ich glaube Container in Container in Container geht besser als Container in Container.
So noch besser als einfach nur Container oder vielleicht sogar gar nicht.
Das finde ich übrigens an LXC schöner.
Dann den Container wieder wegschmeißen.
Ich finde es sollte halt Plan geben.
Es kann doch nicht sein.
Ich meine gut, dass es zumindest internettechnisch keinen Plan gibt.
Das wissen wir.
Das ist uns klar.
Woher weiß ich jetzt, ob Docker läuft?
Dart, Docker, einfach so.
Das geht auch nicht.
Okay, Container in Container mit Container geht schon mal nicht.
Woher weiß man denn bei Snap, ob was läuft oder nicht?
Ich verwende den Kram so selten.
Und startet ist er ja.
Crap.
Stop.
Piss dich alle.
Ja LXC ist wirklich nice.
Aber warum?
Wenn ich jetzt zwei Jahre an eine BBS Fachrichtlinie Informatik gehen würde, würde ich dann
wissen, was du dort machst.
Weil ich nicht erkläre auch nichts.
Eigentlich wollte ich das überhaupt nicht machen.
Ich dachte mir eigentlich nur, ich mache kurz nebenbei mein Home Assistant neu, aber irgendwie
geht der Docker krempeln.
Da haben wir gelitten.
Das war eigentlich mein erstes Video, was ich hier auf dem Channel noch habe.
Kommen wir mal zu dem, was ich einsparen wollte.
Sollten wir ein bisschen YouTube Motivation holen, oder?
Aber wir haben auch noch andere Probleme.
Ich bin ja prinzipiell eigentlich außer Mann bei der Bahn ausgenommen.
Die Bahn bash ich gerne.
Ich finde es immer blöd, so quasi sinnlos Leute zu bashen, so nach dem Motto, ja, XY
hat keine Ahnung, weil er hat keine Ahnung, so nach dem Motto, irgendwie alle Politiker
sind doof.
Das sind so pauschale Dinge, wo ich mich dann immer frage, wie kommt man dann zu der Annahme
und sowas.
Aber wir haben ja noch andere Probleme.
Die Leute sind zum größten Teil auch ziemlich doof.
Das kommt ja noch dabei.
Und jedes Mal, wenn irgendwie ein Artikel, das heißt ja, wenn du auf dem iPhone guckst
und nach links switch, da kriegst du ja manchmal News angezeigt, weil Apple meint, die News
sind jetzt relevant für mich.
Ja, Cortana, nicht alle.
Nicht alle.
Die Leute, die hier zugucken, wahrscheinlich weniger.
Die sind wahrscheinlich genauso doof wie ich, weil gleichartige, doofe Leute ziehen
sich irgendwie an.
Und was wollte ich jetzt sagen, genau.
Und da gibt es dann ab und zu mal News, so nach dem Motto, das weiß man nicht, über
Elektroautos oder das mal wieder, dass irgendwo neue Höchsttemperaturen gemessen wurden oder
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Und da ist meistens auch der Spiegel dabei.
Und dann mache ich dann manchmal so die Spiegelartikel auf und dann liest man dann irgendwas nach
dem Motto, dass das jetzt irgendwo auf einmal irgendwie zwei Grad wärmer ist als im Durchschnitt
und dass hier irgendwie da und da was droht abzutauen und so.
Und dann muss man sich die Kommentare durchlesen.
Alter.
Bei Klima News, ja.
Also da weiß ich nicht, was mit den Leuten teilweise abgeht.
Ich meine, mittlerweile ist ja in den Kommentaren, sind sie sich zumindest einig, dass das Klima
wärmer wird.
Sind sich ja sowohl die pro-Klima-Leute als auch so die kontra-Klima-Wandel-Leute, sind
sich ja eigentlich mittlerweile überall wenigstens einig, dass die Entwicklung nicht so toll
ist.
Das aktuelle Streitthema ist, wo sich die Leute immer übelst die Körbe einschlagen
Und ich finde das halt teilweise so geil.
Die Frage ist ja dann immer so nach dem Motto nicht mehr.
Also früher war die Diskussion so nach dem Motto, ja ja, alle Klima-Erforscher erzählen
Blödsinn.
Na, das stimmt doch alles gar nicht.
Blah und sonst was.
Mittlerweile, was schaust du dir hier gerade an?
Eigentlich nur mich, wie ich in meiner Shell sinnloses Zeug tippe, weil ich eigentlich
was ganz anderes machen wollte.
Und ich jetzt ein bisschen Zeug erzähle nebenbei.
Und dann wollten wir uns eigentlich Videos angucken.
Naja, zumindest, mittlerweile sind sie sich ja einig, dass es halt wärmer wird.
Und jetzt ist die große Preisfrage und die große Diskussion, die dann immer läuft,
so nach dem Motto, verarschen uns nicht alle Klima-Erforscher.
Verarschen uns nicht alle Klima-Erforscher.
Da kommen dann so Leute anstatt, die schon ein bisschen länger leben.
Und die kommen dann an, so nach dem Motto, das ist alles Schwachsinn, alles scheiß Klima-Lüge.
Und früher wurde mir erzählt, der Regenwald stirbt oder ist bis heute nicht gestorben.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, alter, warst du mal da?
Da soll ich mal manche, da soll ich mal Google-House-Aufnahmen angucken.
Die soll ich mal Google-House-Aufnahme angucken.
Außerdem, man hat ja auch die letzten Jahre viel dagegen gemacht.
Ich mein, nur weil der Baum, die Logik der Leute versteh ich nicht,
nur weil der Baum vor der Haustür noch steht, ist das nicht, dass klimamäßig alles in Ordnung ist.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie die Leute aus so grandiosen Ideen kommen.
Naja, zumindest wird da immer drüber diskutiert, so nach dem Motto, wir sind uns jetzt ja einig,
es wird wärmer auf der Erde und liegt das denn jetzt daran, an dem was die Menschen fabrizieren
oder liegt das denn jetzt an, ja an was weiß man nicht so genau.
Erzählt es immer so, liegt es, es geht eigentlich eher darum, liegt es jetzt, ist es jetzt von Menschen verursacht
oder ist das jetzt halt mal wieder so weit.
Ja, und da sind so viele Leute dabei, wo ich das Gefühl hab, diese komplett,
so komplett an der Realitätsverweigerung irgendwie dran,
da werden dann Dinge ausgebuddelt, die nach dem Motto so, ja, neuste Forschungen,
neuste Klima-Lügen-Forschungen, die Leute schreiben das ja dann auch so immer so geil,
glaub nicht dem Klima-Papst, blablabla, da haben sie jetzt mal wieder irgendwas ausgebuddelt,
irgendwie so eine Eisschicht in Grönland, man stürzt sich ja auf alles irgendwie, was einen quasi
in seine Weltbild unterstützt, ja, und da haben sie jetzt wieder irgendwas in Grönland ausgebuddelt
und da haben sie so ein paar Eisschichten in Grönland, ich glaub in Grönland, im Prinzip ist es auch egal,
haben sie irgendwie ein paar Eisschichten in Grönland untersucht und haben jetzt rausgefunden,
ha ha, in Grönland von vor, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht, keine Ahnung, ich sag jetzt einfach mal,
in Grönland von vor 500.000 Jahren, da wurde es auch schon mal innerhalb von ganz kurzer Zeit,
ganz furchtbar warm, ja, mag ja sein, vielleicht, das ist auch ja drauf gefurzt oder so, was weiß ich,
also quasi, wenn man ein Ding irgendwie findet, wo man dann halt eine Sache hat, die nicht ganz klar ist,
die der Sache ja manchmal widerspricht, ja, die nicht ganz klar ist, bestärkt das die Leute dann wiederum
weiterhin in der Ansicht, nee, nee, das ist, das ist alles schon okay, also, wir können ohne Probleme
weiter Zeug verbrennen und tun und machen und Plastik ins Meer werfen und so, das ist alles kein Problem,
das ist nicht menschgemacht, das kann nicht sein, nein, das ist nicht so, ich mein, der Zusammenhang
zwischen, man guckt sich die, ich mein, man muss ja noch nicht mal Sonder-, man muss ja noch nicht mal
mit irgendwelchen Verschwörungstheorien anfangen, wie das manche Leute machen, muss sich einfach angucken,
wann die Leute angefangen haben mit Industrie und massig Produktion und Zeug und wie sich das Klima
verändert hat, da kommt man eigentlich, und selbst wenn man, und selbst wenn man es partout nicht haben
möchte, muss man sich immer eine Sache fragen, will man es wirklich drauf ankommen lassen, das ist ja
der eigentliche Knackpunkt, es ist vollkommen egal, ob man jetzt wirklich davon überzeugt ist oder sagt,
ja, die große Klimalyuge und wir werden alle verarscht und so, okay, selbst wenn es so sein sollte,
die Frage, die man sich ja stellen muss, ist, will man es wirklich drauf ankommen lassen, ja,
und der kann doch eigentlich keiner drauf antworten, so, ja, machen wir, geil, perfekt, irgendeine Stadt
in, glaube ich, Thailand oder so, die haben jetzt zwei Meter hohe Mauern, weil sie mittlerweile, oder
noch höher, weil sie irgendwie mittlerweile zwei oder drei Meter unter Meeresspiegel liegen,
ich glaube, wenn du mal da jemand fragst, der hat da wahrscheinlich andere Ansichten zu, naja,
ich verstehe das vor allem in der heutigen Zeit, ich verstehe das einfach nicht, weil das kann ich,
ich kann das einfach nicht verstehen, weil in der heutigen Zeit, das ist eigentlich so simpel,
also wisst ihr, in Zeiten, wo es schwierig war, Informationen zu bekommen, ja, und noch schlimmer,
wo manche Leute nicht mal richtig lesen konnten, gut, YouTube Deutschland lassen wir mal außen vor jetzt,
in Zeiten, wo man wirklich relativ simpel was nachgucken kann, ausgerechnet heute sind ganz viele Leute
der Überzeugung, dass offensichtliche Sachen gelogen sind, ich verstehe das überhaupt nicht,
und mir geht es jetzt nicht um die 0a15 irgendwie Verschwörungstheorien und so, ich denke,
bei vielen Sachen liegt die Wahrheit oftmals nicht exakt bei der offiziellen Version und auch garantiert
nicht bei der Verschwörungstheorie, sondern ich gehe auch davon aus, dass uns an vielen Stellen
nicht exakt immer die Wahrheit erzählt werden, man sieht das eben schon im Thema vorher,
aber so ganz offensichtliche Sachen, wo sich teilweise die Griechen schon darüber im Klaren waren,
so wie das die Erde eine Kugel ist oder sowas in der Rechnung, dass man ausgerechnet in der heutigen Zeit
auf die Ideen kommt, das wäre fake, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie man auf die Ideen kommt, ja, ja,
und wenn man sich dann so ein paar Videos anguckt von so Leuten, in der Regel läuft das ja so nach dem Motto
seid kritisch, hinterfragt alles, glaubt nicht den offiziellen Medien, nein, die sagen, nein, das stimmt nicht,
die sagen, glaubt nicht den offiziellen Lügen, glaubt nicht, die schieben das den Leuten schon so unter,
mach jenes hier und das nicht, hinterfragt das, seid kritisch und wenn du dann mal allerdings guckst
und bei denen was hinterfragst oder bei denen was genauer wissen willst, da werden sie übelst aggressiv,
so nach dem Motto, ja, glaub nur weiterhin deinen Mainstream Scheiß, du wirst schon sehen, was du davon hast,
anstatt es einfach mal zu erklären, wie er auf die Idee kommt, ja, das Lieblingswort von,
ich mein damit jetzt nicht so was wie Reptilien oder so was, weil sie irgendeinen Chat geschrieben haben,
das Lieblingswort von so Flach-Erd-Leuten ist ja unter anderem Perspektive, die finden das übelst geil,
Perspektive ist somit das, damit kann man alles erklären, wenn man sich mal ein paar,
ich hab mir ja ein paar Flach-Erd-Videos angeguckt, Perspektive, also wenn du zum Beispiel fragst,
so nach dem Motto, ey, wie geht denn das, dass wenn es flach ist, ja, dass ich dann, keine Ahnung,
den Messeturm jetzt von Frankfurt nicht sehe, keine Ahnung, aber Perspektive, the fuck, ja,
oder die beste Erklärung, die ich mal von jemand gelesen hab, ist, wo es auch darum ging, ja okay,
wenn ich jetzt quasi, so nach dem Motto, warum sehe ich denn das Hochhaus nicht, wenn ich da und da stehe,
hab ich gesagt, ja klar, weil was hier im Weg steht, absolut arg, gut, ach, daran erkennt man,
dass die Erde flach ist, weil was hier im Weg steht, ha ha, beste Erklärung, vielleicht 10, ey,
das ist big brain, das ist absolut big brain, weil was hier im Weg ist, und, was auch immer toll ist,
Moment, ähm, was wollte ich jetzt sagen, fuck, jetzt hab ich was im Skype geschrieben,
bei Skype in 2k18, jetzt hab ich vergessen, was ich sagen wollte, ja, was wollte ich denn sagen,
das war auch noch irgendwie so geil, das hab ich auch letztens gesehen irgendwie, ja, genau,
als Begründung, als Begründung hat dann auch irgendjemand gesagt, ähm, genau, es ging darum,
es ging darum, wenn du, wenn du eine Drohne hast, ne, wenn du eine Drohne hast und du stehst,
du parkst die am Meer, also, keine Ahnung, du parkst die irgendwie auf dem Strand,
parkst du da eine Drohne, also ein Quadrocopter, und dann wartest du, bis die Sonne untergeht,
und du wartest, bis, bis du von der, also du machst die Kamera von der Drohne an, ja,
du wartest, bis du nichts mehr von der Sonne, quasi über die Meeresoberfläche, ähm, schimmern siehst,
ähm, TF, so, und dann, das ist das was, was dir auch kein, äh, kein Flacherdtyp erklären kann,
ähm, und dann fliegst du mit der Drohne einfach mal hoch, ja, und auf einmal siehst du die Sonne wieder,
und dann denkt man sich so, wie geht denn das, die hätte sich ja eigentlich schon wegdrehen müssen,
oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, oder, oder was auch immer, ja, und dann, wenn man dann quasi,
das, das, das war in einem Video, ja, und da hat er dann gefragt, so nach dem Motto, ja, quasi Herr Flacherdtyp,
erklären sie sich das denn, und da hat er gesagt, weiß er nicht, unser Modell ist ja auch nicht perfekt,
aber, ähm, die offizielle Version ist für ihn nicht einleuchtend, äh, ah ja, beste, beste Erklärung schlechthin,
beste Erklärung schlechthin, weiß ich nicht, aber die offizielle Version, die kann es nicht sein,
die kann es einfach nicht sein, das geht nicht, ich weiß es nicht, aber nein, die offizielle Version leuchtet mir nicht ein,
das ist vollkommen uneinleuchtend, ja, also vollkommen vorbei, das kann nicht sein.
Die sollen mal links hier, die sollen mal Alexander Gerst oder so auf Twitter folgen,
sich ein paar Fotos aus der Welt angucken, das sieht halt schon alles irgendwie, ach, egal, scheiß drauf, äh,
das ist auch so ein Thema noch, äh, da, da verstehe ich echt die Welt bei sowas nicht mehr,
ja, das ist dann das nächste, genau, dass das Kamerabild manipuliert ist oder sowas.
Ja, Pawel und Manus ist wirklich so, Fakten scheinen echt keinen zu interessieren,
also was, was man auch belegen kann irgendwie, ne, und, und wenn man es dann belegt,
dann kommt dann sowas raus wie, na, das leuchtet mir jetzt aber nicht ein.
Ja, Moment, es geht doch gar nicht darum, ob es ihm einleuchtet oder nicht,
es geht doch gar nicht darum, ob es ihm einleuchtet oder nicht,
es ist ein Unsinn und Zweck der Sache.
Da hatten sie auch letztens was, ähm, ich, ich weiß auch nicht, warum ich mir so viele Videos von diesem Besten angucke, ja,
ähm, da ging es irgendwie drum, also es haben sie irgendwie, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie sie es gedreht haben,
also sie haben quasi so, so dieses Argument, dass wenn du, wenn du im Vakuum zwei, wie haben sie das denn gemacht?
Zumindest haben sie so dieses, dieses Experiment gemacht, dass wenn du quasi zwei Sachen im Vakuum fallen,
dass es dir halt gleich schnell fallen, so, und, ähm, also egal, was du fallen lässt, also, ne,
also du kannst, du kannst eine Holzkugel fallen lassen oder eine, ist es im Prinzip egal,
so, die kommen zur gleichen Zeit unten auf dem, auf dem Boden an,
und das haben sie irgendwie so gedreht, ich meine, wenn da Luft dazwischen ist, geht es natürlich nicht,
ähm, das haben sie irgendwie so gedreht, so nach dem Motto, dass das ein Beleg dafür ist, dass es irgendwie,
dass ich die eher nicht drehen kann oder irgendwie sowas, und ich meine, wie kommt man denn auf sowas,
im Prinzip ist es ja eigentlich eher ein Beleg dafür, dass es eben so ist, weil es dich anzieht,
und dich kann es nur anziehen, weil ziemlich viel drunter ist, naja.
Naja, ähm, ich meine, eigentlich ist es ja irgendwie ganz logisch, ne, eine schwerere Kugel,
die da quasi in Ruhe, ist schwieriger zu beschleunigen, wird zwar auch stärker angezogen,
aber ist schwieriger zu beschleunigen, eine leichte Kugel ist einfacher, also einfacher zu beschleunigen,
wenn sie in Ruhe ist, und dann ist es irgendwie ganz logisch, dass das gleichzeitig unten ankommt,
ich weiß nicht, wie man sich daraus, ähm, sowas zusammen reimen kann,
es müssen sein, die Luftblase der Wasserwaage in der Mitte, ja.
So, jetzt sind wir ja ganz, äh, abgeschmiffen irgendwie,
ich glaube, da machen wir das mit dem Video gucken morgen, äh, bin ich jetzt schon da?
Ah, eine Stunde 17, ich habe jetzt wirklich eine Stunde, fast eineinhalb Stunden irgendwie,
Zeug geschwätzt, äh.
Was meinst du, Wouts müsste konstant beschleunigen?
Ich weiß nicht, ob was das, und so, äh,
Clobos, Clobos Videos jetzt, ja.
Also, was war denn das erste Video, was ich, was ich hier habe?
Man kann ja bei YouTube auch nicht mehr zurück, das ist ja zu, äh, High-End-Funktion.
Ach so, jaja, ach so, das meinst du, ja, theoretisch schon.
Also, das müsste, das müsste sich nach oben quasi Gas geben, im Endeffekt, dass du drauf,
dass du immer, immer gleich drauf gedrückt wirst, ja.
Ah, da habe ich viele Videos.
Ist das alles aus einer Zeit, wo ich schon viele, viele Videos, wo ich echt, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Nice, ha, ha, ha, kenn, kenn das noch jemand?
Der Fabian am Start.
Nice, mit dem Turtle Beach damals noch.
Was, ich kann nach Elston sortieren?
Oh, Klasse Funktion.
Viel zu Video, nein.
Ha, ha, wo kamen wir her?
Ähm, nein, natürlich machen wir sowas nicht.
Ähm, ich logge mich, weil Account-Sharing ist ja verboten.
Ich logge mich natürlich immer mit meinem Account ein und lasse ihn dann damit spielen.
Klar, oder? Wir würden nie gegen Toss verstoßen, nie.
Ist der Frisur eigentlich on? Nee.
Okay, was habe, was habe ich denn damals für Zeug hochgeladen?
Max ärgert sich Hackerlobby, die kann ich mich gar nicht mal richtig dran erinnern.
Wartet mal, jetzt müssen wir uns jetzt mal anhören, was habe ich denn da erzählt?
Oh, wenn ich mich selbst aus der Zeit damals höre, ey, oh.
Wo ein KS.
Ich hoffe, ihr erwartet nicht, dass ich das jetzt kommentiere.
Oh Gott, ich kann mir das nicht anhören, oh.
Bäh, nein, nein, nein.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Oh je, Cringe on top.
Naja, gut doch.
Pray and pray, dass mir so schnell keiner nachmachen wird.
Nein, ich zeige es euch deshalb, bam, in your face, Flashbang.
Dafür gibt es eine Post, das ist cool, wusste ich auch noch nicht.
Naja, gut.
Ich wollte euch heute eigentlich ein bisschen Gameplay zeigen.
Ich weiß, ich habe gesagt, Hetzard, Gamer Hetzard, mache ich wahrscheinlich nicht das Mal.
Ich habe auch schon eine Mail gekriegt, wie Sie sagen.
Ich mache es, allerdings, dieser Channel ist für Gameplay.
Und guck mal hier, wie der rumfliegt.
Stimmt irgendwas nicht, oder? Was, der fliegt rum?
Wo fliegt da einer rum?
Ich wollte euch etwas Gameplay zeigen, und zwar wollte ich euch ein Free for All, ein Flawless Free for All zeigen.
Ein Flawless Free for All?
So ein Flawless Free for All schüttelt man natürlich nicht so einfach mal aus, aus dem Armgelenk.
Was, hä?
Oh, der glitscht da rum.
Man braucht Gameplay, was sich zu kommentieren lohnt.
Ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen, das ist nicht das Flawless Free for All.
Guck mal hier, wie es hier durch den Türrahmen haut, wenn man anschießt.
Das ist nicht das Flawless Free for All, was ich euch zeigen wollte.
Denn ich bin in einer ganz merkwürdigen Lobby gelandet, als ich gespielt habe heute.
Gut, dass der hinter der Mauer kämpft, ist noch nicht merkwürdig.
Das ist eher normal.
Das tut weh beim Zugucken.
Ich bin in einer Hacker-Lobby gelandet.
In vier selten da gewesen bisher.
Anscheinend gibt es irgendwelche neuen Bugs, oder es ist ein Typ, der seine Xbox-Geflecht an einer Custom-Code ausführen kann.
Ich glaube, das Video ist nicht so spannend.
Ich glaube, da passiert nicht wirklich was.
Außer, dass ich mich über irgendwie Hacker-Zeug aufrege.
Und endlich Munition.
Es haut die Gegner quer über die ganze Map, wenn man sie trifft.
Gut, das war Glück.
Das war nicht gehackt.
Ja, das ist das erste Video, was ich habe.
Die ersten zwei Videos, die habe ich nicht mehr auf dem Channel, weil da hatte ich Musik drin.
Ich glaube, das ist das dritte Video, was ich gemacht habe.
Das erste ohne Musik.
Ich hatte im allerersten Video, hatte ich...
...Code 5?
Ich glaube, im zweiten hatte ich Code 4.
Da hatte ich Intro- und Outro-Musik.
Die apokalyptischen Reiter, Intro-Musik und irgendwas von den Toten Hosen Outro-Musik.
Und das habe ich daraus genommen, weil ich nicht wollte, dass das Jahre später noch vielleicht Probleme macht.
Dass da einer hinter der Tür kämpft, ist auch normal.
Allerdings...
Wir gucken mal, ich hatte...
Ich hatte das mal irgendwo hochgeladen, das erste Video von mir.
Hallo, Jungs und Mädels.
Oh je, hör ich mich da völlig an.
Ja!
Das ist wirklich das allererste Video, das hatte ich damals anlistet, hochgeladen nochmal.
Noch ohne Hallo, Jungs und Mädels, ey.
Du musst noch ein bisschen lauter machen, ein bisschen leiser.
Oh Gott, Grinsch.
Oh Gott, hätten wir das auch geschafft.
Das tut weh beim Zuhören.
Oh Gott.
Irgendso ein 2 Euro billiges Headset, wo der Kopfhörer schon nicht mehr ging.
Noch lauter.
Wie alt war ich da? Das Video ist von...
Nein, Moment.
2010.
Also, da kannst du...
Ich hab angefangen im November 2010.
Also sprich, kannst du 8 Jahre abziehen.
Und jetzt bin ich... nicht der Scheiß, äh, 34 bin ich jetzt.
Ja, QuickMuffs, wie alt war ich da?
BigShark.
QuickMuffs, richtig cool.
Wow, sag mal, irgendwie hab ich den Sound nicht richtig abgemischt, das ist jetzt voll laut, oder?
Was ich übrigens nice finde, am Ende hatte ich noch so ein Outro drinne.
Ich war 69.
Am Ende hatte ich irgendwie noch so ein Outro drinne.
Und was da drinne stand, war übelst cool, warte mal.
Wow.
Da hatte ich den Outro draußen drinne.
So, und warte mal, was am Ende steht.
Guck mal, guck mal.
Nächstes Video wahrscheinlich, du einkommst mit meinem Kumpel den Friseur.
Damals noch mit Z.
Heute ist er ja der Eifrisi.
Damals war es der Friseur noch.
Das war schon nice.
So, was haben wir sonst noch für Ollos Zeug?
MW2, Free4All, 30, 4.
Ich kann mich an fast jedes Video erinnern, wenn ich hier so durchscorele.
Fast.
Aber das sagt mir gar nichts mehr.
Das sagt mir überhaupt nichts mehr.
Damals waren es nur die Jungs, damals gab es noch nicht die Mädels.
War noch keine Grills.
Boah, Vorgass.
Es klingt auch besser als das erste Video, ne?
Es klingt auch schon besser.
Das ist der beste Video, den ich je gesehen habe.
Aber guck mal, was dabei rauskommt.
Ich muss dazu sagen, diese Map habe ich, glaube ich, einmal vorher gespielt.
Ich habe mir die Map Packs geladen und quasi gleich vergammeln lassen.
Ich wollte es eigentlich gar nicht mehr spielen.
MW2 hat mich damals übelst abgefuckt, das weiß ich noch.
Das Spiel, ich meine, ein bisschen was muss das Gameplay hermachen.
Ich benutze das Standard Killstreak Setup.
Tah21? Was, lauter?
Also überhaupt nichts Tolles.
Ja, das muss doch gehen.
Ich kann euch auch gar keine Tipps geben, weil ich der Meinung bin,
das Spiel MW2 ziemlich schlecht.
Zumal, wie gesagt, ich kenne die Map nicht und was soll ich da groß machen?
Ich camp ein bisschen rum, ich schieße ein paar Noobs ab.
Der hat mich genauso gut messern können, hat er nicht.
Habe ich auch mal Glück gehabt.
Anscheinend, wie man hier sieht, ganz viel, ganz tolle Sniper am Start.
Man sieht hier nur Ghillie-Suits und irgendwelche komischen Kriegsgopern wieder mal.
Aber ich meine, die Waffen im MW2 sind zu über.
Guckt euch das an.
Einmal in die Nähe gehalten.
Dann werden sie weggepascht.
Ja, platt ist er.
Das Einzige, was mir eigentlich nachhaltig gefallen hat an MW2, muss ich sagen,
waren die Sprecher, also die Voice Acting.
Das fand ich wirklich gut.
War das Voice Acting in MW2 so geil?
Kann ich mich jetzt überhaupt nicht dran erinnern, dass ich das so geil fand?
Na, sagen wir so, in bisher allen Cod-Teilen war das Voice Acting eigentlich ziemlich geil.
In Modern Warfare 2 finde ich es besonders gut,
zumal ich sagen muss, das ist eigentlich das einzige Cod-Spiel,
in dem mir das Singleplayer deutlich besser gefallen hat als der Multiplayer.
Das ist im Nachhinein auch wirklich immer noch so.
Ja, ja.
Der Singleplayer, auch wenn er...
Ich finde, die einzigen Singleplayers, die mir gefallen,
zu richtig ist Cod 4, MW2 und Black Ops 1.
Ich habe fast jeden gespielt, aber die anderen fand ich alle ziemlich blöd.
Ja, sagen wir mal, nicht gerade originelle Storyline hat.
Es gab ein paar wirklich Gänsehautmomente, meiner Meinung nach,
komplett zuzuhören.
Das müssen wir uns ja nicht komplett anhören, was ich erzählt habe.
So, Flawless, Freefall mit der G36C, TDM Shotgun,
Flammenwerfer Only 38.
Was ich hier alles gemacht habe.
Medal of Honor.
Das war das.
Das war das da.
Ich erinnere mich noch dunkel.
Das war das Reboot Medal of Honor.
Oh, WTF.
Wobei, das ist nicht das Reboot vom Reboot.
Das fand ich ganz gut.
Das fand ich ganz gut im Multiplayer.
Die offensiven Killstreaks sind nicht sonderlich überpowered.
Doch, das ist das erste Reboot.
Das ist nicht Warfighter.
Das ist...
Das war Warfighter.
Nee, nee, das ist nicht Warfighter.
Das ist auch nicht Call of Duty Ghosts.
Warfighter war das Failgame.
Guck mal, 2013 war das, nee, 2010 oder so.
Das da.
Das ist das.
Das ist das, mit dem Typ, mit dem Bart.
Das ist das, mit dem Typ, mit dem Bart da.
Genau, weil Warfighter war ja dann das da.
Das war ein richtiges Kackgame.
Und das fand ich gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Da hat glaube ich auch DICE mit gebastelt damals.
Das fand ich gar nicht so übel.
Bisschen Friendly Fire, ha?
Und die Quali...
Wie viel Battlefield 3 aus...
Das ist ja von der Engineer wahrscheinlich mehr oder weniger auch.
Okay, ähm...
Wir warten auf den DHL-Mann, mein...
Da kann ich mich auch überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Was ist das denn?
Also das ist die COD-4-Bonus-Mission.
Auf Veteranen und die war wirklich schwer.
Schauen wir uns die mal an.
So Jungs, hier ist der Max und wir warten nicht aufs Chrisken.
Nein, wir warten auf den DHL-Mann.
Krass.
Was ein Intro.
Der uns nämlich heute Black Ops bringt.
Die automatische Senderverfolgung funktioniert nicht.
Da irgendwie die DHL das nicht auf die Reihe kriegt bei Express-Sendungen, das gescheit zu managen.
Das hatte ich schon öfters, das sackt.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, es wird gleich auftauchen hier.
Problem ist, ich muss um spätestens zwölf losfahren, um mir dann noch eine zweite Version zu holen.
Nämlich die AT-Version.
Ich möchte das mal ein bisschen vergleichen und AT und Dings und sonst was und okay und überhaupt.
Und ich muss mich ablenken, deswegen spiele ich hier eine Runde Mile High Club und warte bis der DHL-Mann kommt.
Ich habe ungefähr 30 Versuche gebraucht.
Ich zeige euch jetzt schnell den Versuch, wo es geklappt hat.
Ich hoffe bei euch war der DHL-Mann...
Die Bonusmission ist wirklich schwer, die COD 4 Bonusmission auf Veteran.
... schon da und hat euch eure Black Ops-Version gebracht.
Und das große Problem ist, wie gesagt, ich muss um zwölf Uhr losfahren.
Um meine zweite Version Black Ops abzuholen.
Du kannst nicht warten, du musst gucken, wie eng die Zeit ist.
Wenn der DHL-Mann mit der ersten Version noch nicht da war, dann kann ich das nicht entgegennehmen.
Was ja meine komplette Planung durcheinander werfen würde.
Das würde extrem sacken.
Weil ich weiß, sollten ja eigentlich Express-Lieferungen bis zwölf Uhr da sein.
Das heißt, der Typ hat noch eineinhalb Stunden Zeit und dann hoffen wir mal, dass das in der Zwischenzeit klappt.
Ab dann gibt es vielleicht heute Abend, wenn man noch Xbox Online spielen kann, bis dahin...
Ich fand mich übrigens geil, als ich die Mission so packt habe.
... und sonstiges Zeug streiben und wahrscheinlich total sacken werde, weil ich noch keine Ahnung habe, wie sie spielt.
Aber das werden wir dann sehen, hoffen wir, das klappt heute und ich hoffe, euer ist schon da.
Und ihr könnt vielleicht schon ein bisschen Singleplayer spielen oder sonst was.
Und hopp's aus dem Flugzeug. Bis heute Abend, tschüss, macht's gut.
Auch voll verdrängt.
War mein erstes Black Ops Gameplay ein Gun Game?
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, ja...
Oh, jetzt sind die Mädels auch mit am Start.
Auf Veteran fand ich die übelst schwer.
Es kann sein, dass es auf dem PC einfacher ist, weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich fand's auf der Xbox, also Veteran, ähm...
Veteran, äh, die Bonus-Mission, Gott...
Veteran hast du weniger ausgehalten und hast irgendwie 20 Sekunden Zeit, also...
Wenn ihr mein letztes Video gesehen habt...
... und das macht brutal Spaß.
Allerweise sowas wie ein Kill.
Die Noobs, die Noobs sind am Start, guckt's euch an.
Diese Raketenwerfer, das ist normalerweise sowas wie ein Killstreak.
Ohne total rein.
Hau total rein.
Am Ende kommen die explosiven Dinger, danach kommt...
Ach, ich verrat's nicht, seht ihr ja gleich.
Danach kommt Armbrust und als letztes...
Oh, mal gucken, wie ich mit dem Ding treff.
Mit der Armbrust versau ich jetzt erst mal ein bisschen.
Man muss sagen, das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Also diese Armbrust ist ein One-Hit, wenn sie trifft.
Die Armbrust war so ein ganz merkwürdiges Ding in Black Ops 1.
So ein ganz merkwürdiges Ding zwischen Server-Side und Client-Side.
So ganz, ganz komisch.
Also sprich, das Ding ist irgendwie losgeflogen, Server-Side...
Und dann war es Hint-Detection, Client-Side.
Ganz, ganz merkwürdig irgendwie.
Sprich, je nach Server-Verbindung flog der Pfeil anders.
Warum ist der denn vorbeigegangen eben?
Er muss sogar ein bisschen vorhalten.
Ich hab vorbeigeschossen, ne? Ich dachte, er läuft da rein.
Wir haben wirklich so ein bisschen Flug-Physik.
Auf Physik?
Mit der Armbrust habe ich festgestellt.
Deswegen werde ich jetzt hier auch nicht...
Sticky.
Das letzte ist das Ballistic Knife.
Also sprich, das Messer, das man hier so schießen kann.
Da habe ich...
Das habe ich aber damals unwissend richtig gemacht.
Du musstest...
Du musstest genau so musstest du das machen.
Weil, wenn du so ein bisschen gestraft hast, dann ist es da in die Richtung geflogen.
Das war unwissend, dass ich das...
Ich, ganz ehrlich, so Sachen wie die Armbrust, das Ballistic Knife, der Tomahawk...
Das war irgendwie cool, damit Leute zu claschen.
Black Ops Sharp Shooter Live.
Black Ops 148.
Ich habe da teilweise am Tag drei Videos gemacht zu der Zeit.
Und ich würde das auch gerne wieder machen, wenn ich ein Game hätte, worauf ich so abgehe, ey.
Ich weiß, dass CSGO den gleichen Modus hat.
Das ist ja auch von CS geklaut gewesen, das Spielmodus.
Overwatch Gameplay, ja, das habe ich leider zu einer Zeit gemacht, wo ich mir danach Overwatch Gameplay auch mal gemacht habe.
Oh, mit dem Friseur, ist das das erste Video mit dem Friseur?
Ich glaube, das ist das erste Video mit dem Fabianne.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Fabianne.
Und wir haben heute einen Gast, wir haben ja nämlich den Friseur.
Und das ist auch das Gameplay vom Friseur.
Hallo Friseur.
Hallo.
Ja, dann erzähl uns doch mal, was du hier so spielst.
Ja, also von mir seht ihr heute hier an, äh, Stuttgarmen Gameplay. Und zwar spiele ich mit der Spass-Spiele. Hier sehr schön zu sehen, die kleinen Doppel-Own.
Doppel-Own, aaaah, das ist so schlimm am Zugucken.
Ja, da bin ich dann bei 26,5 oder 6, glaube ich. Das ist jetzt die so tolle Arbeit, die ich jetzt eben sehe. Und das wollen wir euch jetzt auch zeigen.
Ich meine, wir haben es uns ja vorher schon mal angeguckt, so ist es ja gar nicht, dass wir jetzt hier irgendwie da blind rangehen an die ganze Sache.
Und es sei schon mal so viel verraten, es gibt da eigentlich ein paar ganz geile Sachen dabei.
Ja, ähm, was bevorzugst du denn für Parks?
Zung? Äh, das liegt am Stream. Bei mir ist es exakt, exakt Zung irgendwie.
Leider, wenn du, wenn du Shotgun spielst.
Also ich finde ja, bei den Perks brauchst du unbedingt Marathon, weil Shotgun musst du schnell in die Gegend rankommen und du brauchst nicht nur Marathon, sondern du brauchst Marathon Pro, weil erst bei Pro schaltest du das unendlich oder das dauerhaft sprintenfrei.
Und ohne geht es eigentlich gar nicht.
Ja, das klingt logisch.
Dann benutze ich noch Sleight of Hand. Viele werden sagen, Sleight of Hand B2.
Also wirklich synchron ist es echt nicht.
Ja, das wollte ich jetzt eigentlich eh fragen. Was spricht denn für Sleight of Hand statt Steady Aim?
Ähm, es ist schwierig. Ich habe jetzt schon ziemlich viel mit der Shotgun gespielt.
Also, ähm, es ist schneller nachladen und schneller wieder retten sein. Ihr seht ja, ich raste ziemlich durch die Gegend.
Es ist keine Seltenheit, wenn du mit der Shotgun spielst.
Du bist einfach zu langsam ohne Sleight of Hand. Also wenn du mit Steady Aim spielst, das klingt zwar auf dem Papier viel besser, aber meiner Meinung nach...
Also hör zu, der Fabian erklärt das wie mein Kot Shotgun-Spiel. Bestimmt heute noch gültig.
Ja gut, man muss ja auch sagen, die Shotguns, die haben ja auch alle relativ wenig Schuss.
Und da wird man bestimmt oft gebashed, während er nachlädt.
Genau, das ist nämlich das Problem. Und wenn ihr das mal spielt mit Steady Aim zum Beispiel, bleibt es unglaublich langsam.
Ja, da haben wir ja irgendwie Shotgun-Woche. Ich habe ja auch noch ein paar Shotgun-Videos gemacht.
Ich sehe jetzt Sentry Gun. Was hältst du von der Sentry Gun, wenn wir gerade dabei sind?
Das war halt geil, man konnte was über das Game erzählen.
Das ist das, was irgendwie so ein bisschen fehlt jetzt, wenn man halt kein Game hat, was man geil findet.
Oh, DPS.
Das ist ziemlich stark, wenn man die gut platziert, wie so wie ich jetzt hier gerade in dem Video.
Ihr seht hier auch, ich läd' die Zitze immer total weggebacken, weil ich sie total verpeilen.
Aber der Sound ist schon richtig schlecht, oder?
Hier noch eine.
Wie fandest du das?
Naja, man sieht ja schon, dass das eigentlich ganz gut abgeht.
Und ich denke, das ist auch mal gut abwechselnd im Vergleich zu den anderen, den Standardwaffen, mit denen man so rumrennt.
Wie findest du denn die Waffen-Balance?
Oh, das, das, das. Das ist das alte Thema.
Also, ich finde die Balance schon gut, muss ich sagen, was mein Problem ist.
Darüber haben wir ja schon mal gesprochen.
Mich stört ein bisschen, dass man so wenig...
Gute Balance.
Ich würde jetzt sagen, oh Gott, was ist das, ich erinnere mich nur bei MW2 und hier Meta-Camp und was weiß ich nicht alles, aber ich finde hier im Black Ops 1 irgendwie ziemlich ähnlich.
Deshalb habe ich in der letzten Zeit auch nur Shotgun gespielt, weil es drauf ist, dass es was anderes ist.
Aber ob ich nur eine Assault-Rifle oder mit der MP5 rumrenne...
Da hat er insofern aber recht, finde ich.
Das ist echt nicht schlecht von...
Also die Balance war nicht gut zwischen den Waffen, muss man sagen.
Es gab Waffen, die waren einfach kacke, mit denen hast du nichts gerissen.
Aber ich fand es ganz gut, in Black Ops 1 hatte irgendwie jede Waffe noch so ihr Ding.
Die SMGs waren ein bisschen copy-paste, ja, aber ansonsten war wirklich...
Fand ich das gut?
Es gibt ja ein paar Leute, die sagen, dass die AK-74 U total über ist oder sonst was.
Die war auch total OP.
Das war mega OP, am besten noch Griff Rapid Fire.
Nee, Extended Mag Rapid Fire oder wie hat man AK-74 U gespielt?
Ich denke, da muss man mal einfach gucken, ob das in einem Monat immer noch stimmt.
Ich meine, am Anfang kann es ja sein, dass es dann überhaupt vorkommt.
Du hast ja erzählt, du hast schon Monat Morphier 2 gespielt.
Ich weiß auch, dass du Lockout 4 und 5 gespielt hast.
Wir haben ja schon eine Weile zusammen gespielt.
Man muss dazu sagen, auch wenn das Video alt ist,
aber ich glaube, wir kannten uns damals auch schon irgendwie an die 10 Jahre oder so.
Was gibt es da jetzt noch zu sagen im Vergleich zu Monat Morphier 2?
Wie findest du denn, dass die Gegner mehr aushalten?
Ich finde sie sehr gut, aber manchmal, also in Verbindung mit den Waffen,
dass die auf keinen Fall relativ stark verziehen.
Ich meine, ich habe immer das Gefühl, man muss irgendwie ein bisschen gegensteuern,
damit man einigermaßen dann trifft.
Also man muss relativ viel zappen auch zwischendrin und zwischen einer Seite und einer Seite nicht wechseln,
und dann geht das schon.
Also vom Spiel her muss man sich schon ein bisschen umdrehen.
Und noch das alte Xbox-Menü her,
was sie dann bei der Xbox One einfach übertrieben verkackt haben.
Wer ist dieser YouTube, von dem du Videos guckst?
Ich habe gerade einen Channel gefunden, der Cod-Videos mal gemacht hat.
Was bringt Ninja nach dem Patch?
Das ist ein Titel, da würde heute jeder was anderes drunter verstehen, oder?
Da würde heute jeder an alles denken, bloß nicht an Black Ops 1.
Da würden die Leute dran denken, wie gut ist Ninja in Fortnite nach dem Patch oder sowas.
Hallo Zeitwächter, was sagst du zu der Switch?
Konsole finde ich nicht übel, vom Konzept her fehlen die Games.
Ich weiß, dass es prinzipiell viele für Nintendo-Verhältnisse, viele gute Games gibt.
Leider ist der Online-Modus kacke bei dem, wo es einen gibt, aber das ist halt Nintendo.
Aber für mich ist nicht viel dabei, außer Mario und Zelda.
Wo ist das Nuke Town Flame-Video?
Ich glaube, da hatte ich irgendein Video gelöscht, wo ich mich so übertrieben über die Cod-Map aufgeregt habe.
An das Video, den magst du auch, okay.
Ballistic Knife!
Warte, ich habe eine Ballistic Knife-Gameplay gemacht?
Oh, das war eines der ersten Videos mit Intro?
Ich habe auch keine Killstreaks.
Alter, was ist mit dem Sound los?
Ich habe gar nichts. Ich spiele aber im Free-For-All mit Killstreaks.
Aber ich habe keine ausgewählt.
Was ist mit dem Sound los, Max? Was hast du denn da gemacht?
Ums Ballistic Knife geht es mir allerdings gar nicht mehr so.
Ich möchte allgemein mal ein bisschen über das Gemessere reden.
Ballistic Knife sollte niemand nehmen, der das ernsthaft spielen will.
Was habe ich mit dem Sound gemacht?
Gegen das Ballistic Knife habe ich gar nichts.
Das ist eigentlich eine richtig lustige Sache und überhaupt nicht zu stark, weil es ein Sekundary ist.
Das ich die zwei treffe, das ist absolut Glück.
Das war nice.
Der zweite war nice, oder?
Ich habe die zwei treffe, das ist absolut Glück.
Ich war nicht so bekannt mit dem Ballistic Knife, aber Glück.
Es geht mir aber ums allgemeine Messern.
Die Kommentare von damals sind langweilig.
Die schreiben einfach, dass es ein gutes Video ist.
Da wird sich nicht geflamed oder so.
Das Problem ist an der Sache, das ist ja eigentlich ein Shooter.
Das ist es zum größten Teil auch.
Das ist nicht mehr als Modern Warfare 2.
Allerdings hat da so eine Nahkampfattacke meiner Meinung nach überhaupt nichts drin.
Der Max hat damals schon die Dinge richtig gesehen.
Wäre das Messer komplett sekundär oder gäbe es eine Perk dagegen?
Meinetwegen wäre das ein ganz anderes Problem.
Das Dumme ist, mit Panic Knifing...
Ich weiß, es ist oftmals tatsächlich Reaktion und ich panic.
Das war die Zeit, wo ich mich dann über das Messer zu drücken.
Das sieht man total oft.
Man sieht einen, schießt auf einen und was macht er?
Anstatt zu versuchen, dass durch geschickte Bewegungen...
Was? Warum hat er das nicht getroffen?
Und was macht er?
Anstatt zu versuchen, dass durch geschickte Bewegungen...
Was war das denn?
Anstatt durch geschickte Bewegungen...
Über Steuerungs-FPS am Start.
Anstatt zu kontern, drückt der Messer.
Ich will nicht sagen, das ist Panic.
Das ist aber einfach ein Automatismus, den man sich angewöhnt hat.
Ja, da hat er schon Recht.
Viele zumindest.
Da hat er schon Recht.
Jetzt rede ich so, als wäre ich das nicht, der damals was erzählt hat.
Weil man gemerkt hat, dass man oftmals damit das noch rumreißen kann.
Und das ist ja eine Sache, die eigentlich nicht sein darf in einem Spiel, wo es darum geht...
...besser zu spielen, als der andere und dadurch zu gewinnen.
Da hat man German Taters.
Man sieht es total oft in meinen Besonder-Free-for-All-Videos.
Ganz, ganz oft schieße ich auf einen und der macht nicht...
...der legt sich nicht hin oder sonst was.
Der versucht das nicht, mich irgendwie auszuspielen.
Nein, der messert einfach.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, ich reg mich jetzt die nächsten zweieinhalb Minuten weiterhin.
Was habe ich denn für Stats am Ende?
Ehm, egal, das Video ist fertig.
Stats?
Max?
Weil es mir ermöglicht...
Ehm, ihr guckt euch das an, WTF ey.
Mal greift das Messer Auto-Aim und mal nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich möchte das noch ganz schnell...
Ich habe Rage-Grid hier jetzt.
Das Tactical Layout möchte ich aus dem Grund spielen, weil es einfach...
Okay, es gibt keine Stats sehen wir nicht, ne?
Na ja.
Okay, was haben wir sonst noch?
Fragen und Antworten wahrscheinlich mit dem Fabian, ne?
Alter, Video übersteuert.
Max, was hast denn da gemacht?
Ja, Frisur, weiß.
Fernladung-Defense-Taktiken.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max und der Frisur.
Frisur.
Wir zeigen euch heute, was man denn so gegen RC Cars machen kann, was da so für Taktiken gibt.
Ja.
Wenn man ehrlich ist, eigentlich konnte man gegen RC Cars nicht wirklich viel machen.
Ich erkläre euch da genau was dazu.
Ihr habt jetzt sicherlich, genauso wie ich am Anfang, immer dieses Problem mit dem RC Car,
dass man das einfach nie trifft und dann an diesen hässlichen blöden Teil stirbt.
So, ja, ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal, wie man es normalerweise immer macht.
Ja.
Und abkackt.
Da bin ich auch mal gespannt.
Ich weiß es nämlich nicht mehr.
Das einzige, was...
Was konnte man bei RC Cars machen?
Ich meine, das einzige, was man machen konnte, ist den Kram abschießen, oder?
Oder dich verstecken.
Und abkackt, genau.
Und ja, ich spiele das Video einfach mal ab und ihr seht ja selbst.
So, man hört das Ding irgendwo.
Der versteckt sich jetzt einfach, oder?
Er versteckt sich.
WTF, ein kommt.
Oh Gott, oh Gott, oh Gott.
Und dann kommt es.
Und dann fängt man an.
Oh, wo fährt das lang?
Oh, da muss ich ziehen.
Und dann ist man schon tot.
Folgendes ein Tipp.
Wenn ihr das Auto irgendwo rumfahren habt, versucht nicht gerade hinter der nächsten Ecke zu
stehen, ja, dass es wirklich dann um die Ecke fährt und euch gleich weg.
Ich glaube, er hat absichtlich vorbeigeschossen.
Würde ich jetzt einfach mal vermuten, oder?
Sondern so, dass ihr ein bisschen Einsicht habt.
Wobei, nee.
Also, dass ihr irgendwo einen schmalen Gang habt.
Nee, das ist ein normales Gameplay.
Oder, dass ihr eben weit genug gucken könnt.
Also, ihr seht ja hier, wir sind im Private Game und...
Wisst ihr, wir waren doch im Private Game.
Wir haben das doch aufgenommen.
Ich kann sagen, das war kein normales Game.
Wir haben das ein bisschen gestellt, aber viele Situationen erkennt man dann auch wieder
im Spiel wieder.
Weil wir es teilweise echt probiert haben, so, also tatsächlich so zu fahren, wie wenn
man wirklich treffen will.
Genau.
Also, wir haben uns jetzt irgendwie auf die Gerade gestellt und dann habe ich gesagt,
Max, fahr mal los.
Ich bin schon rumgerannt und Max hat mich versucht, eben mit dem Teil zu killen.
Aber ja, wie man es dann macht, seht ihr gleich im nächsten Clip.
Jetzt kriegen wir es gezeigt.
So, also das erste, was ich gesagt habe, nehmt die Clemore.
Ihr seht Rückzugspunkt, ihr seht das Auto, der Gegner sucht mich.
Ich leg das dann einfach in diesen schmalen Gang.
Gut, das kann ich mal anders hinfahren.
Und zack, jetzt ist es gebashed.
Das ist kein schlechter Tipp gewesen.
Das ist wirklich, das ist richtig durchdacht.
Das ist nicht einfach nur Clickbait gewesen, das ist wirklich, wirklich durchdacht gewesen.
Ihr könnt es ja oft machen, wenn ihr eben schmale Rückzugspunkte habt.
Also der nächste Tipp, wie kill ich das Teil mit der Waffe?
Ihr müsst vor euch zielen, nicht auf das Assika, also vor, dass es genau rein fährt.
Nach unten, nach hinten laufen und wirklich gerade halten.
Weil, wenn das Teil euch killen will, die Leute fahren eh geradeaus.
Und irgendwann fährt das sozusagen.
Will der Rapidfire?
Ist das AK-Pinze zu Rapidfire?
So, schwierig wird es natürlich dann, wenn der Gegner den Turbe einsetzt.
Also das ist hier viel zu weit nach vorne gezielt.
Ihr müsst wirklich so mehr auf den Boden zielen.
Dann hätte das hier an der Stelle geklappt.
Und wie gesagt, die Waffe in ihr bewegen.
Na ja, das dauert aber ein bisschen bis Dema, wenn Peek kommt.
Uno mit der Sylvaner, oder?
Nee, nur mit dem Fabian.
T-Shirt Gewinnspiel.
Guckt mal, ich hab damals schon Progas gemacht.
Guckt es euch an.
Damals, damals gab es schon Progas im Stream.
Pro-gars.
Stringer-Rader raus.
Oh, das ist so nice.
Da war es schon, das ist von 2010.
Damals gab es schon Progas-Stream.
Und jetzt können wir auch schon mal eine Aussage treffen, wie viele Leute mitgemacht haben.
Oh Leute, alte YouTube-PN-System. Endlich mal.
Ach die Synthia war ja auch noch am Start, aber das habe ich alles vollverdenkt.
Achja.
So, wo ist denn das erste? Das ist schon, das ist schon MW3, oder? Ach nee, die Crysis 2? Ich habe eine Visur zur Crysis 2?
Wir spielen Schleifklasse, ja bleibt einem leider nicht... Oh, ich hatte, ich hatte, hört jetzt, ich habe ein besseres Mikro.
So. Oh also ich muss mal ganz ehrlich sagen, grafisch ist das okay, aber das ist jetzt nichts, was mich irgendwie so wahnsinnig riesig sonst was vom Hocker hauen würde bis jetzt eigentlich. Ach nicht so...
Crysis? Was, Little Big Planet mit dem Fabian? Killzone, oh das war die Steuerung, die Steuerung von Killzone, das war so schlecht am Anfang.
Kann man bei YouTube irgendwo das Alter des Abos anschauen? Ich kann es gucken, glaube ich, wenn ich eingeloggt bin.
PS3 Move? Moment, ich hatte mal einen Move Controller? Ich kann mich wirklich nicht daran erinnern, jemals einen Move Controller in der Hand gehabt zu haben.
Unboxing mit dem Friseur, das war auch nice. Warum mit einfachem Weg, wenn es auch einen schwereren gibt?
Das ist doch scheiße hier. Oh, habe ich jetzt in einem Reifen geschnitten, das ist schlecht.
Oh nice. So, aha, hier gibt es Pet Company.
Wo ist denn das erste Battlefield Video? Das muss doch jetzt irgendwann mal kommen.
Das ist ein Battlefield.
Oh, Xenobad Company. Counter Strike Gun Game? Ja, ich hatte mal sogar ein Counter Strike Gun Game.
Die haben mal Halo gespielt, das weiß ich alles. Ich hatte ziemlich viele Bad Company 2 Gameplays, so wie ich das sehe.
Und die war nice damals, die Bad Company 2 Gameplays. Da habe ich geschneibert, ohne Ende.
Da wurden sie weggeschneibert. Wie, der ist nicht down? Jetzt aber down.
Das Video vom Tom ist so gut angekommen. Das fand ich echt cool, denn eigentlich war das mal was anderes.
Was soll ich mit dem Controller Aim sagen? Mit dem Controller Aim geht es doch voll klar.
Quick Scope! Bam, Messer! Jawoll!
Ich fand PC2 mal auf dem PC auch gut. Ah, hier, Battlefield 1. Battlefield 3 Beta. Jawoll, Battlefield 3 Beta.
Warum genau, wenn ich mit der UMP rumgestellt auf Metro damals?
Gab es da noch den LLV in der Beta? Ist das ein LLV da hinten? Es gab nämlich mal auf Metro einen LLV in der Beta oder in der Alpha.
Nee, ich glaube das gab es doch schon immer. Gewinnen wir die Runde? Shotgun! Guck mal, wie damals das Hat noch gewackelt hat.
Alter, der Teilo hat gebashed. Guck dich das mal an. Für Beta?
42.11 in der Beta. Wie sich das aktuell darstellt ist der rechte Laufweg. Aktuell kommt er mir am besten vor.
In der Hoffnung man wird nicht gekillt.
Company 2 mit Company. Auch Damacy XD, der mit der Fernsehstimme. Damals war er nicht so. Der Kieler Junge war am Start hier.
Hammerman P-Garage Attacker. Das müsste so das erste Battlefield 3 Video nach Release gewesen sein denke ich mal.
Ist das mit Simone 95 oder wie sie hieß? Nee, wenn ich sage ich habe das schon öfters erwähnt dann ist das nicht das erste Battlefield Video.
Nee, das ist das erste. Nee, das ist Beta? Keine Ahnung. Weihnachtsstimmung. Lens vs Zombies, das habe ich auch gespielt.
Ich fand das nice. Ich hatte damals eine richtig gute Mischung und zwar vor allem aus Games die mir Bock gemacht haben oder zumindest Bock gemacht haben zu gucken.
Das war richtig gut. Das Problem ist ich würde es gerne genauso weitermachen, allerdings habe ich keine Games die mir so gut gefallen.
Das ist echt das Problem was ich habe. Das ist das größte Problem was Videos machen angeht eigentlich. Wow. Unser schlechtestes Video. Oh nee, Silvano das kenne ich noch.
Das ist das Winter Silvana wo sie erzählt hat dass sie ihre Titten zeigt. Hallo Mädels und Jungs hier ist die Silvana. Und der Max und der Pippe. Wir zeigen euch heute ein Gameplay von dem Friseur und von mir beide Flawless.
Und wenn ihr bis zum Schluss durchhaltet dann bekommt ihr auch noch einen kleinen Leckerbissen. Das hat sich über Jahre gehalten. Jetzt das blöde Gelaber.
Die Betonung liegt auf Leckerbissen. Oh ja sehr lecker. Und nachdem wir gedacht haben wir müssen unsere weiblichen Zuschauer mehr ansprechen, werden wir heute auch noch was ganz tolles machen.
Das stimmt, das ist wo der Fabian die InTouch Mode Zeitung oder was das mal rausgeholt hat und dann irgendwas vorgelesen hat. Oh man. Es guckt man jetzt nicht ganz an.
Oh man. Tja. Minecraft 360 Edition. Das haben wir ja auch gespielt. Wo wir uns den Boden verbuddelt haben. Wo Minecraft noch zu Zeiten von ein sinnloses Minecraft Video einfach mal 240.000 Aufrufe gekriegt hat.
Und das legendärste Video aller Zeiten darf ja auch nicht fehlen. 2 Millionen Views Alter. 2 Millionen Views. 2 Millionen Views als ich durch den Garten gelaufen bin.
Das war ein Video. Ich habe von der Baustelle hier vom Haus ein paar Videos gemacht. Hätte YouTube mal ein ordentliches Video von mir so promoted hätte ich heute 500.000 Abos oder so.
Aber nein. Was wurde promoted? Das komische Garten Video. Wo ich einfach nur durch den Garten. Das war Fail. Oh man. Das war doch jetzt ganz lustig.
Das war jetzt ganz lustig.
Oh man.